[موسيقى]
افضل الصور هي تلك الصور التي
تحتفظ بقوتها وتاثيرها على مر السنين
بالرغم من عدد المرات التي ينظر
اليها
حسين شاب بالجيش العراقي انفجرت عليه عبوه
ناسفه وفقد احد ساقي وطبعا مثل كل شاب
عنده طموحات واولها كان ان يتزوج
طبعا فقد
الامل انشرت قصه
حسين وحازت على اهتمام بعض المنظمات
بحيث حصل على
على رجل اصطناعيه
و قدر يتقدم بخطبه البنيه بعد معاناه كلش
كبيره لغايه ست
شهور قدر يتزوجها
وقدروا يجتمعون ببيت
[تصفيق]
واحد طبعا تقدر الصوره الجامده تمنح
الحركه للحياه اللي كانت
متوقفه
داعش والاحداث الغير الانسانيه اللي مرت
على العراق ضحيتها اطفال
نساء احداث
الموصل فاجع
اليزيديين والناس اللي نزحت وما قدرت ترجع
لا
اهاليها ناس ايام مشت حافيه حتى توصل لبر
الامان
اطفال تبكي من الخوف والرعب بعد ما شافت
الموت والقتل لمده اسبوع او
اسبوعين
الفلوجه طف مراه شايله بتها وطبعا تدور
على بر
الامان طفله شايله جنطه طبعا ويا اهلها
تحاول
تلقي اقرب وسيله نقل حتى توصل لاقرب مكان
وتقدر ناس ما تقدر
تمشي و ولا حول ولا
قوه
سبايكر اكثر من 1700 عائله ما تعرف مصير
اولادها لذلك المصور الصحفي
الحربي لازم يتحلى بالشجاعه والجراء
والمهنيه وهو يتوقع بموت اي لحظه ولازم
يقدر يشتغل
بهوايه ظروف مختلفه بظروف صعبه حتى ايش قد
تكون التاثير كبير
لذلك هاي الاحداث بما اسيها هاي الاحداث
بمسها
وفرحتها خلتني افكر ان اشتغل على موضوع
اخر نقدر نبين الجانب الاخر من المعاناه
لذلك التقيت بصديقي المخرج محمد مونيكا
وقدرنا
نفكر
و نقدر نطرح موضوع
جديد حتى تقدر توصل للناس بكل سلاسه توصل
لكل بيت من خلال السوشيال ميديا
فقررنا انسوي مشروع هابي
[موسيقى]
بغداد
دعتنا القضيه ودعانا حب الوطن الى
ان نرجع ونقدم خدماتنا الى اخواننا
المجاهدين من كل فئات المجتمع من سنه ومن
شيعه
ومن مسيح ومن شبك كل الناس المظلومين احنا
قضيتنا قضيه واحده واتحدنا واتفقنا على
انه نحارب داعش برغم اختلافاتنا الطائفيه
والقوميه والعرقيه فنجد هناك الاخ المسيحي
وهناك الاخ الشبكي والاخ الكردي والسني
والشيعي يقاتلون جنبا الى جنب ضد هذا داعش
وهذا المعسكر نموذج بسيط الى قوه
ونقاوه اللحمه
العراقيه
هنا يتدرب المسيحي ويدرب من قبل مسلم
ويدرب من قبل شيعي ويدرب من قبل
[موسيقى]
سني
مريم طبعا صورنا هذا العمل بكل عفويه
مصداقيه
صورناها بدون
ان نسوي عليه ايديتينج كبير او نسوي عليه
تحرير كبير فلذلك
حاولنا ننقل
قصص من بيوت او اماكن الناس ما تقدر
تشوفها وخاصه بالعراق لذلك احنا ركزنا ان
نشتغل بهذا الوضع على موضوع واحداث وقصص
ما نقدر
[موسيقى]
نشوفه
قلتل
[موسيقى]
ودوني ما مشتاق مشتاق بس
لابوي اشوف قد ما
[موسيقى]
شايف
انا صغير فت كلشي ماعرف ه علمون الصلاه
علمون الاخلا ايش يعني كانت اشياء
بحش جت من الفلوجه صز
الفلوجه
ابوي كان يقتل بي ويعذبني كان
يشده يشدني وحطنا
[موسيقى]
بالشباك
وبالنهايه نتمنى قدرنا
نوصل رسائل حقيقيه من الجيش اللي كان جامع
جميع اطياف المجتمع الناس البسطاء
والفنانين واللي رادوا من خلالنا
يوصلون رسائلهم
للناس بالعراق كامله ولذلك وهاي الرسائل
من اهلنا من ساحات
المعركه نقدر
نشوفه
رساله الى اهلنا ببغداد و محافظاتنا
العراقيه الحبيبه ان شاء الله احنا يعني
اوشكنا على انهاء داعش بالعراق وان شاء
الله هاي نهاياتهم انفاسهم الاخيره فلوجه
انتهت ان شاء الله واهالينا اللي بالفلوجه
الابرياء واحنا محررين لا مدمرين ذول كلهم
مجرمين وامراض نفسيه لا تتوقعون احنا راح
نكون يعني قاسين عليكم او شي احنا اهلكم
وارحم بكم من الدخيل ومن الغريب ان شاء
الله ما يفصلنا غير ساعات وايام بسيطه عن
تحرير نقيب عمر نسار قياده فرقه الرد
السريع وما راح اقول طوائف كلهم اهلنا
وبالذات اهل الفلوجه اللي احنا جايين
وعافينى ومتغربين وجايين من محافظات بعيده
احنا جايين نحرر ونخلص من ظلم داعش خصوص
المحافظات افرحوا وتنسوا طلعوا ادرسوا
حبوا تزوجوا احنا موجودين صحيح احنا
متغربين عايفين عوائلنا بس احنا خلقنا
لهذا الشيء على مود نخليكم تعيشون بامان
وتعيشون بحياه سعيده ونامل حياه حلوه
لاطفالكم المستقبل جميل المقاتل رئيس
عرفاء حيدر عل عبد الساده قياده فرقه الرد
السريع مدمات
[موسيقى]
الخاصه
[تصفيق]
شكرا
ه